>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Well good
afternoon and welcome to the African
and Middle East Division
of the Library of Congress.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb
chief of the Division
and I'm delighted to
see you all here.
To again this presentation
which we are co-sponsoring
with the European Division
and Regina is not here
at the moment but she'll be coming.
And the presentation is
on the Jews of Posen,
by Mister Edward David Luft.
As most of you already
know our division is made
up of three sections.
The African, the Near East
and the Hebraic sections.
We're responsible for materials
from 78 different countries
in the Near East Central
Asia, The Caucuses as well
as from the entire continent of
Africa and North and Sub-Sahara
and also for the Hebraic
collections we're responsible
from collections coming
from all over the world.
We always very active in
acquiring, developing collections,
briefing visitors coming from
all the countries of the region.
And organizing programs, symposium,
workshops, exhibits and so forth.
We also invite scholars and experts
who have done research and work
in our areas of responsibility.
And we invite them to share with us
their insights and their findings.
So that all of us attending and
participating in the programs leave
and reach with new information
and a better understanding
of the countries and societies
with publications we collect.
Today's lecture is a case in point.
Mister Luft has been working on
this book for a number of years.
Here at the Library of Congress and
has used resources in this division
as well as in many other divisions
including the European division,
including the geography
and map division.
And we have the chief
of the geography
and map division here,
Ralph Ehrenberg.
The general collections,
HSS and many other parts
of the library as well.
And Mister Luft will tell you
more about this in a moment.
But now our very own
Sharon Horowitz,
the senior reference librarian
in the Hebraic section.
Will introduce Mister
Luft and the program.
So thank you.
>> Sharon Horowitz: Thank
you, thank you Mary-Jane.
Good afternoon, on behalf
of the Hebraic section
and the European division,
welcome to the African
and Middle Eastern reading room.
I especially want to thank
the European division
for co-sponsoring today's
lecture with us.
As you heard my name
is Sharon Horowitz
and I'm reference librarian
in the Hebraic section.
The Hebraic section marks
its beginning in the 1912.
With the receipt of
10,000 Hebrew books
and pamphlets who's purchase
was made possible by gift
from New York philanthropist
Jacob Schiff
from those humble beginnings
our collections have grown
to around 250,000 items in Hebrew,
Yiddish, Ladino, Judeo-Persian
and other Hebraic script languages
and our holdings also include
an important collection
of Amharic books.
Two of our missions in this division
are to publicize our collections
and to bring people
into the library.
One way we do that is by
holding lectures such as this.
Today's speaker, Edward David Luft,
is an individual who has lectured
and published widely on the
topic of Posen Province.
Furthermore because of his scholarly
diligence he is a well known
researcher in the Library of
Congress having done research
in many of the library's divisions.
Today's presentation is
focused on Mister Luft's book,
the Jews of Posen Province
in the Nineteenth Century,
a project that has kept
him busy for 28 years.
Mister Luft graduated with an AB and
JD degree from Syracuse University.
He spent two years in Botswana
in the Peace Corps and worked
for the New Yorker Magazine
before coming to DC and working
as an attorney for the US
government from which he is retired.
I want to express my appreciation
to Mister Cliff Fulwood
[assumed spelling] from Binding
and Miss Deborah Healy from
cataloging for their beyond the call
of duty assistance in getting
Mister Luft's book cataloged
and bound in expedited manner.
But before I turn the podium
over, I have one item of business.
This event is being videotaped
for subsequent broadcasting.
There will be a formal question and
answer period after the lecture.
At which the audience is encouraged
to ask questions and offer comments.
Please be advised, that your
voice and image may be recorded
and later broadcast
as part of this event.
By participating in the Q and
A period, you are consenting
to the library's possible
reproduction
and transmission of your remarks.
And now, please join me
in welcoming our speaker,
Mister Edward David Luft.
[ Applause ]
>> Edward Luft: First let me say
thank you to Mary-Jane and to Sharon
for their kind invitation to speak.
I am quite grateful,
I'm also grateful
to see a relatively large turnout as
some people who's faces I recognize
and others who are welcome as well.
Before I get started what I would
like to do is tell you a story
that would've been contemporary
with the 19th century.
You probably are aware, or at
least many of you will be aware
that the Jews probably could
not have survived without humor
in the circumstances in
which they found themselves.
So this would be a typical story,
the old man on his deathbed
opens his eyes and sees his son
and asks what is that wonderful
smell coming from the kitchen?
And the son says, mom
is making apple strudel.
Oh says the dying man,
if only I could have some
of your mother's apple strudel
I could die a happy man.
I'll get it for you poppa,
I'll get it for you poppa
and he rushes to the kitchen.
A little while later he comes
back very dejected and says,
momma says the strudel is
only for after the funeral.
[ Laughter ]
Well it's good to know
that some people still find
that sort of thing funny.
That would have been typical
and I have other stories
of a similar nature that
you might find interesting.
But let me get started.
I do not write out
what I speak about,
I prefer to do it extempore
basically
and so we'll see how long it lasts.
If it sounds kind of mixed up maybe
if I forget something I'll
go back and tell you later.
Let me start here, the picture
that you see on the screen,
is of the administrative
district of Posen.
And you see it on the top
in German and on the bottom
in Polish in abbreviation.
And this is the intermediate level
of government between the province
of Posen and the city of Posen.
So we have three levels
of government.
Each called Posen.
Very confusing.
Each had a very clearly defined
role, but you had to thread your way
through and get to the right
office to get the right thing done.
Very very bureaucratic,
very pressuring.
Let me tell you a little about
how I came to write the book.
I was looking back in
1983, 1984 for a book
that I knew had existed at one time.
A compilation of what turned
out to be 5,134 names of Jews
who were naturalized, in the grand
Duchy of Posen in 1834 and 1835.
Based upon a law promulgated
by the king in 1833.
And on my very last, on
the next to the last day,
of my time in Berlin I asked
in what was then West
Berlin, at the state archives.
Where can I see a copy of that book?
And they said oh we have it.
I said could you please
make me a copy?
Yes, come back tomorrow.
And while I'm standing
there, they were making it
and I quick rushed
directly to the airplane.
When I got home, I decided I saw a
need for publication of that book
and all though this is
not the first edition,
this is the revised edition.
Here it is.
And the library I believe has three
copies actually, plus they have the,
excuse me the 1987
edition of the book.
And we estimate, or at least
I estimate that about 47.8%
of those naturalized
are represented.
That means, not that
every name is there,
but rather essentially every family.
Or 47.8% of all of the
families, the Jewish families
in Posen would be represented.
So notice it's less than half.
Not everyone was naturalized
as a Jewish citizen.
It was not the same thing as
full citizenship, it was second
or third class citizenship.
But it did give some rights,
more were given in 1847
and the rest basically didn't occur
until after the fall of the kingdom.
In other words until the
Weimar republic was proclaimed.
That is not so different
from other places
in Britain they used
different criteria,
but for example full
professors got six votes.
Compared to, ordinary
citizens who got only one.
And this would've been
until I think 1921
or something like that, in Britain.
Has nothing directly to do
but it gives you a comparison.
I'm not entirely sure how
much the audience knows
about the history, so forgive me.
You can ask questions at
the end, if I have lost you.
I wanted to show you next, yes.
This is Alexander Subkind Bernstein.
Isn't it a marvelous portrait,
it's owned by a lady who works
at the Leo Baeck Institute in
New York City and her brother.
And supposedly there were
originally 13 portraits.
Probably one for the
wife and 11 children.
So far as we know this
is the only one
that has survived it
was brought something
like in 1934 to the United States.
Alexander Subkind Bernstein was
the, I guess we would say, sorry,
the vice president of the
Jewish Corporation in Schroda.
And so he was a man of some standing
but he was also obviously
a wealthy merchant.
And it would have been quite common
to have portraits painted
like that at that time.
To give you some general idea,
the book contains three maps,
this one is of Meseritz which
is in the northeast of Posen.
This is the county or I'm not
sure if Christ is exactly county
but it's something similar.
This is a rather rare map from
1848, this is the libraries,
reproduction of the libraries copy.
The book in which it's found is
not rare but the map itself is.
And because there are many editions
of the book, but without the map.
The libraries copy is
with the map and I hope
that they will make a point of
securing it for that reason.
And this is a kind of busy
difficult to read map,
but this is Posen Province in
1905, it's a quite common map
that can easily be found online.
And you could enlarge it etcetera.
If you notice, to the right, is
the Russian Empire and to the west
of course would be Berlin
and Brandenburg and so on.
I wanted to include
those in the book,
oh and by the way this
is the book right here.
In four bindings but it's one book.
And it has 14 different chapters
plus some additional information.
The first chapter is
Landsmanshaftn, those are,
for those who don't know what
that is, those are organizations
which looked after the
interests of the Jews locally.
They were voluntary
associations and so some of them
for example would make loans,
usually it was a question
of burial and burial insurance.
But it could have been
almost anything
that the community
felt in need to have.
And it might encompass
visitations of the sick and so
that would be called [foreign word]
and other kinds of associations.
There is a book published by
YIVO in New York which details
at least their holdings in New York
and may include some other places.
I compiled the information from
the Jewish Theological Seminary,
the Leo Baeck Institute and
various manuscripts listed
in holding of various entities.
I think I should tell you that I
used resources in the United States,
mostly New York and
Washington DC, but elsewhere.
Also Denmark, France,
of course Germany
and Poland and oh and Brazil.
I cannot say of course
that I caught everything
but I tried to catch quite a bit.
And you can see it's
nearly 2,000 pages,
that's why it took me
more than 28 years.
What I can say is that it's an
exhaustive list of Lansmanshaftn
to the best of my ability.
The second chapter deals with
Mormon records, website resources
and especially the Amstsblatt of
the royal government of Posen.
That's an interesting
publication in many ways.
Because in the earlier
years, there was no newspaper
of general circulation
in the Province.
And as a result you see ads
in the [foreign language],
the general notices which were
attached to the Amstsblatt,
amsts is a location and
blatt is a newspaper.
So it's a local newspaper.
The, I was surprised when
I first started to look.
The Amstsblatt are
for, were published
in almost all German
speaking locations.
Okay. Thanks.
The Amstsblatt were published
in various locations.
Usually for every Province, thank
you, for every Province in Posen.
I'm sorry in Prussia, but
also the Austrians, the Swiss,
many others had similar
publications and the Library
of Congress has many of these.
Also most of them are now online
and can be searched
even from your own home.
However you do need some
knowledge of German.
The, what really surprised me
was that in [foreign language]
of the attachment to
the Amstsblatt itself,
in the early years one
frequently found out in Hebrew.
Because there was no other
place of general availability
of this kind of information.
That did not continue
once there were newspapers
of general circulation
in the Province.
Next, there were, I discussed
German archival holdings.
That's a difficult problem in a way,
because on the 29th of January 1945,
the retreating German army set fire
to the then Pol's and archives.
Burning everything that was in it
except for 80 chests of documents
which were taken away and we
don't know what happened to those.
Perhaps they're in some salt
mine or something like that.
We don't know.
You would think that they probably
would have been found by now,
if they were going to be found.
It's a great loss.
But in 1919 a German Jewish
archivist inventoried the entire
collection and published
it and I have reproduced
in my book the listing
of what was destroyed.
So at least we know what
doesn't exist anymore
or if it does exist,
has not been found.
A great shame but the, not
everything was in that archives
and so other things
that did survive are now
in the current archives in Poznan.
And are available for
legitimate researchers.
It's amazing what they did manage
to collect and I had lunch once
with one archival curator
and told me,
he told me just the
previous week he came
across valuable documents hidden
from the Nazi's in a barn.
And only discovered long after the
death of whoever hid those items.
So things are sometimes
still being discovered.
It's getting rarer and
rarer but it is happening
and the Pol's have
made a determination
that they will pretty
much put older,
older archival documents
online eventually,
but it's such a large collection
that it will take many many
years before they finish.
Next I looked at Polish archives
and it's of a similar nature
and mostly available in the
state archives in Poznan.
But, you can't be sure of that
because of the various upsets,
not only in World War Two
but also in World War One
where there was a lot of fighting
in Poznan Province,
today the Wielkopolska.
Things got displaced and
sometimes they have been shifted
to the supposedly correct
archive and sometimes not.
So, you basically have to look very
carefully to see where something is
that you want to, to find.
It's serendipitous and you
just have to keep looking.
Next I dealt with Israeli
archival sources.
Most of the archival resources
are in one place in Jerusalem.
The central archives for the
history of the Jewish people.
But again not everything.
Some things are in strange
places, you find archival documents
that are not Landsmanshaftn related
in the Jewish Theological Seminary
in New York or in the Leo Baeck
Institute or in YIVO which is
in the same building and I have
tried to pull it all together
or as much as I can, to help people
understand what they can look
for and where.
Basically trying to make it
easier on researchers who want
to write books or dissertations,
thesis, whatever.
I also have a listing
about onomastics.
And again I tried to be
as thorough as possible,
I'm sure I missed things but
it's a fairly complete list.
And then I went on
to city directories.
With respect to towns that
were formerly in Posen.
Oh, by the way on the
onomastics, the names,
the Prussians had some very
specific rules as to adopting names
and what names could
be adopted, etcetera.
The big difference was unless
it was prohibited by the rules,
Jews in Prussia could
adopt any name they wanted,
that is not necessarily true in
some of the other German states.
But it was in Prussia.
I did try to make an exhaustive
list of known city directories
so that you can see who is listed.
Usually the head of household only.
Not often anyone else
but remember that widows
and spinsters would have been
considered heads of households.
Generally that's how you find out
about women in city directories.
Otherwise generally not, I'm
sure there are some exceptions,
but generally not.
Please excuse me I have a cold.
I asked a friend of mine, Professor
Krzysztof Makowski who is head
of Judaic studies at Adam Mickiewicz
University in Poznan what he knew
about money, weights and
measures from the period.
And he said that he
didn't know anything
and you know the person
most likely to know.
So as a result I wrote a chapter
on money, weights and measures
and you can look there to see what
would have been the then current,
currency or units of
measurement of various kinds.
And so far as I know
it's the only place
where that information has been
generally collected although you
could probably do the same thing I
did and put it together yourself.
Next I worked on all of the Jewish
high school graduates in Posen.
Most people don't know that
the state library in Berlin
in its second cellar has the
largest collection of yearbooks
from high schools in the world.
I know they have Scotland
for example
and I don't know specifically but
I have every reason to believe
that they would have one
of the greatest collections
of high school yearbooks
even from the United States.
I spent many many days
in that second cellar
and when I got finished because
many of those books hadn't been used
in ages, my hands we
absolutely black.
I photo copied as much as I
could, everything that they had
because it lists for boys.
Their names, birth
dates, place of birth,
fathers profession whether alive
or dead and fathers location,
interestingly though not
the name of the father.
And the last entry would be the
current situation of the boy
when he had left the school
and if there's an asterisk next
to his name, that's one thing
about the Prussians
they were consistent in,
everybody in Prussia had to do
the same thing at the same time.
And these yearbooks
were compiled until 1915
when the war situation
became impossible
and so there were none
produced in 1916, 17 or 18.
In 1919 or 1920 the Pol's began
again to do that sort of collection.
But of course with a very
different population in the schools.
And some but very few Jews.
I stopped with the
German ones in 1915.
The thing that's interesting about
the lucky girls who managed to go
to high school is the fathers name
is provided, unlike for the boys.
So it's a great help if you're
doing genealogical research.
Keep in mind that girls going
to high school are a very
privileged group at that time.
So the chances of finding somebody
unless they were relatively rich was
small if they were
girls and even the boys.
A lot of the boys didn't go
or if they did go they may well
not have graduated high school.
But I think that I got every
single school and in some cases
when the state library in Berlin
did not have the information I went
elsewhere and selected it.
And although I didn't
do the Christians,
I turned over the original
records or the photocopies
of the original records
to the Leo Baeck Institute
where they can be found in
the Edward Luft collection
and you can check on the
Christians as well as the Jews.
Then comes the main
part of my book which is
about 9,000 annotated entries
on, from articles, books,
whatever about the Jews of
Posen during the period.
I included the Library of
Congress call number if I found it
at the Library of Congress.
And by the way obviously
if it's annotated I looked
at every single item in the book,
that's why it took me so long.
If I didn't find it here, but I
found it at the New York Public,
I put in the New York
Public Library call number.
If I didn't find it there, I looked
in the Leo Baeck Institute
or in YIVO.
As I've said both in the same,
excuse me, same location.
And put in their call number.
If not, in any of those places,
then wherever I did find
it and that call number.
If it was in the United States,
if it was in a foreign country
I indicated not only the name
of the holding institution
but also the country.
Some of the items are
Portuguese, some in Russian.
It's amazing how many
different cultures dealt
with scholarly articles
on the Jews of Posen.
I was quite surprised, Maya
Bowebine [assumed spelling]
for example wrote some
articles in Russian.
By the way he also spoke English.
And then two chapters on maps.
The first chapter being maps,
that is map series, gazetteers,
aerial photographs and books
containing maps of Posen.
The second chapter is
listings of the maps themselves
and the call numbers because
in a large number of cases,
I listed maps in the
British Library.
They have been collecting for far
longer than the Library of Congress
and they have a large number
of maps that the Library
of Congress does not have.
But that doesn't mean that it's
worth going there necessarily
because the Library of
Congress collections
and the New York Public
Library are so good
that unless you really need
something of a specific date,
you probably can make do with
what the Library of Congress has.
And if not almost certainly
between the Library
of Congress and the New York Public.
So unless you want that specific
map you probably don't need
to go to London.
Although I have.
The last chapter, the
last full chapter is,
a chapter on synagogues
and cemeteries.
Because a lot of people
have written about those
in what is today Wielkopolska.
And so for those interested
one can go there.
I'll just add something
that's not in the book.
And that is that so many Jews
from Posen migrated to Berlin
that when I went through
the largest Jewish cemetery
in Berlin, Weibensee.
I was astounded by how few
grave stones were listing people
who were not from Posen.
Just amazing, just amazing what
percentage there were in Berlin,
so many in fact that until the
Nazi's shut the publication down,
there was a publication that was
dedicated exclusively to Jews
from Posen living in Berlin.
And the Library of Congress
does have a microfilm
with most of those issues.
And I have tried to
list them also there.
I want to say something
about something else,
my friend Angelica Elmoncruga and
her husband [inaudible] knowing
that I was working on Posen, did
not dwell very strongly on Posen.
When they produced this CD, this
is the Library of Congress copy.
Nearly 32,000 annotated
titles on the Jews of Germany
from early modern times until
the end of World War Two.
An incredible amount of work,
published by Harrassowitz,
one of the leading
publishers in Germany.
And I would recommend that if you
don't find somebody in my book,
you might want to look here to see.
I had a question earlier about Link
and Blan [assumed spelling]
two different family names.
While we didn't find anything in
the list of 5,134 people naturalized
in Posen, this is probably worth
a look under those circumstances
to see what there might be.
And this would be available
through Hebraic section here.
Let me just show you one
more picture in the book,
this is Akiva Eger the last
[inaudible] of Posen walking
in a street, this is
actually as [foreign language]
but supposedly it's Posen, it's not,
in fact it's probably Eisenstadt
which is where Akiva Eger was
born in what is today Austria,
but at that time was
Hungary in Burgenland.
And I don't know which one is which
but the other two are his
two rabbinical assistants.
I did include a partial list of
Posen city death records for Jews,
the problem is that in many
cases there's no last names,
so you have to have some
general idea of the person.
I did put in as much as I could
and when I found somebody
listed in my book.
The naturalized Jews
I did note it in,
in the relevant chapter
in that book.
So, that's essentially, oh by
the way the source of those names
from the Posen city death registry
was from a film that the Mormons had
and they had no idea
what it was about.
None at all, so I told them.
So you do find something strange.
I don't know what else to tell you.
The book ends with a little
bit about me and a link
to where you can find
out some of my work.
Perhaps you would like
to copy that down.
Here is what the page looks like.
And there are currently nine entries
there may be some additional entries
in the future, but
that is in my view some
of the most important things to do
this kind of research and again.
I don't know how to get back there.
Sorry can you help me get
back to the previous page?
Good. For those interested, right.
For those interested this is a
bibliography of my publications,
it is approximately 200
entries, a little bit more.
So now if anyone has any
questions I'll try to respond.
Anyone?
>> I want to thank you very
much David it was a wonderful
presentation and very focused
on the type of work that we do
which is collect sources
and bring them together
in work as you have done.
And I'm just curious, why
did you set up doing this?
What is the motivation and
kept you going for 28 years?
>> Edward Luft: Well the real
motivation was the first book.
Having discovered it after
looking so long and not finding it,
it was nowhere in the United
States as it turns out.
Later I discovered that there were
actually two [inaudible] copies.
But the more complete copy was at
Adam Mickiewicz Library in Poznan
and I tried to take as
much information from that
as I could I believe that it is
a complete copy whereas the one
that I found in Berlin
was not quite complete.
And then it seemed
obvious and it ended
up that the tail was wagging the dog
because you can see how much smaller
that book is, than the
2,000 pages of this one.
It was like topsy, it
just growed you know.
And so, once I got
started, typical person
that I am, I just couldn't stop.
Til finally I said okay, that's
it, I drew a line underneath
and said I'm not doing anymore.
Yes Ma'am?
>> Did you trace your
family to Poznan?
>> Edward Luft: Oh yes.
Interestingly none of
them lived in the city.
I'm sorry?
>> Main motivation for researching?
And what happened to the
Jews when the Nazi's came?
>> Edward Luft: They were rounded up
and sent to death camps generally.
But there weren't very many anymore.
Most of them who were going
to leave left by 1923.
The overwhelming majority
went to Berlin,
some went to the Ruhr Valley
especially Essen and some migrated
to the United States, not very many.
Okay. I think Darren first.
>> What percentage of
the information came
from the Library of Congress?
>> Edward Luft: I never
actually calculated it
but I would say the
overwhelming majority.
Okay we had some other
people, this gentleman.
>> So the title is,
The Naturalization?
>> Edward Luft: No, The
Jews of, which book?
The big one?
>> I saw one over here on the side.
To deal with the naturalization.
>> Edward Luft: This one.
This one? Well, can everybody see it
or shall I just say it's the
Naturalized Jews of the Grand Duchy
of Posen in 1834 and
1835, catchy title right.
>> Why would they hide the book?
>> Edward Luft: Well, before
that time they weren't
considered citizens.
Naturalization made them citizens
and gave them certain rights.
But they had to meet certain
criteria in order to be naturalized.
Basically they had to be what
the Spaniards would have called,
Hidalgos, sons of somebody.
In this case mostly
because they had money.
There were restrictions
on living in Posen,
on marrying etcetera
unless they were citizens.
And the government took a
chance, they had no way of knowing
if the Jews would accept
the idea of this sort
of second class citizenship.
And they were very very
relieved when Akiva Eger showed
up to be naturalized under
his German name, Akiva Eger.
And he is in the book therefore.
Professor.
[ Inaudible Question ]
I think we're going to have
to just let me answer that one
because otherwise we could
be here several years.
>> Can you repeat the questions?
>> Edward Luft: Yes.
Professor Dovey wants to
know about the social impact
of three partitions
of Poland on the Jews.
The Pol's and Jews were sort
of in the middle if you will.
Between German Jews and the
what I'll callmthe Russian Jews.
And so they were not always
observant, not always knowledgeable
but they didn't want to admit that.
Most German Jews were
very proud of the fact
that they did not speak Yiddish.
Most Pol's and Jews did
speak Yiddish but especially
in later times might of have
been reluctant to admit it.
And there was always this tension
between reform and orthodox.
They were both congregations
in the city of Posen,
but the orthodox was larger.
Nevertheless there were a
large number of professionals.
Many of those professionals,
but not all, were reformed Jews.
They were orthodox Jews who were
professionals even if we take
out the rabbi's who of course
would be more heavily represented
among orthodoxy.
Any other, yes sir.
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Edward Luft: That is
a matter of some debate
which I discussed in this book.
I'm doing this out of my head,
but if I remember I estimated
that it's about 55,000.
>> Oh it's not that large then.
>> Edward Luft: No and yet
it is a huge percentage
of the Jews of Germany.
Keep in mind that at
its greatest extent,
German Jews were only
600,000 in 60 million.
But if you read the
book, [foreign language]
or in English Germany without Jews.
You can see an examination of
the impact that the Jews had
on German society, I
would recommend that book
and by the way it's written
by a Christian, not by a Jew.
Basically it's very difficult, if
you not only look at which Jews
from Germany obtained
Nobel Laureates,
but also look at those
whose [foreign language],
the faculty adviser of those who
won Nobel Prizes among Germans,
it rises to an astounding 99%.
By the way, you have
to carve out those
who won Nobel Laureates
in literature.
Which makes some sense
because after all we're talking
about German culture there.
But in the sciences and
in the social sciences
which the Germans don't always
distinguish between those two,
there's one word in German.
It's 99%. Now remember
this is not just Jews,
this is those who are either Jews
or whose faculty adviser was a Jew.
That's a little bit off my topic
but I thought it's worth mentioning.
Yes sir?
>> Mister Luft the related
question on population.
Express as a percentage
for the migration.
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Edward Luft: I don't know
and we know that as early
as 1800 there was an
out migration of Jews.
Out of Posen.
So you'd have to know which year
and then look at the census,
there are census records that the
Germans kept to tell exactly that
and you could also look at
the minority census of 1939,
compiled by the Nazi's to see how
many Jews were left at that time.
In that portion of Posen which
was still part of Germany.
Because not all of it was,
the Rump area was put together
as Posen [inaudible] and made
into an administrative
area basically a Province.
>> I realize that you're the expert
and I'm the generalist I was hoping
for some general kind of figure.
>> Edward Luft: Never more than
ten, never more than ten percent.
But you'd have to know the
specific year, etcetera but all
of that is knowable,
you could look it up.
Anything else?
>> I wanted to ask another question.
But why were the boys
fathers names not mentioned
on the records of the schools?
You said the girls
were but not the boys.
>> Edward Luft: Well the girls
were going to get married
and not have a profession.
The boys presumably
would have a profession
and that was the German
bureaucracy's way of dealing
with it, I don't really
know, I can only speculate.
And after all the surname
will be the same.
And they're not really
interested in the father.
Although interestingly
they're very interested
in the fathers profession.
They're interested in
the boy who graduated.
Some of whom by the way
if they have that asterisk
by their name are even excused from
taking the final oral examination.
Because their grades
are so high etcetera.
And therefore I presume that it
would be quite well documented
who they where and where
they came from etcetera.
We know of course the town from
which they came and the fathers town
which is usually but
not always the same.
And some of those people
usually non-Jews but not only,
would come from Russia or
other places to be educated.
Commonly those high schools
taught a second language
as French and English.
And later, there were Jewish
religion teachers just like Catholic
and Protestant religion teachers.
And in some of the larger schools
there was two tracks German
or Polish.
So it, those were pretty
liberal places for the times.
But the rules about what went into
the yearbook was set in Berlin.
Not locally.
So, they didn't have any choice
about what they reported.
>>Sharon Horowitz: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
If Mister Luft has energy and
anyone wants to talk to him
about the more personal or extensive
questions I think he'll stay
and talk with you later but
I just want to thank you all
for coming and thank Mister Luft.
>> Edward Luft: Thank
you, for having me.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.